and with that let's introduce I like to
call them friend of the show now Davey
Jacks what's going on but man how you
doing what's up man thanks for coming
are you sure is a night our show's a
nightmare
um
I guarantee it's hotter in Texas and
I've only thought about jumping off my
balcony twice oh well that's pretty good
then you guys have no humidity I don't
want to hear it
yeah that's what I'm talking about dude
it is awful out here we along with you
it's worse than Florida then Florida
yeah come visit the devil's taint
sometimes yeah see how you like he's
gonna be down here next week oh yeah
where what are we where I mean Tampa so
we're doing that yeah we're gonna have a
club capital of the world trust me I
know Amherst used to be the manager of a
mini
and Tampa Tampa is the city I did I
worked out a lot too yeah yeah dude
thanks for coming on we wanted you back
on ASAP because number one and everybody
[__] loved you and number two we're
too lazy to prep for the show we like to
have guests on it's easy to bring them
on he's funny he'll do the heavy lifting
we want to hear about your trauma for a
while not ours you know what I mean
right I mean we're all trying to kill
ourselves what's what's going on look
either slowly with alcohol or fast with
a bunch of other ways that's why we need
to bring in guests once in a while
because like we can get it merch you I'm
molested you're a drunk we get it you're
not a nice person all right bring
somebody else on and I have to talk
about calls I have an undiagnosed
personality disorder it doesn't matter I
mean we're all [__] up I mean you know
everyone's diagnosed it
like self-diagnosed anything pretty much
yo every [__] who's quirky says they're
autistic now it's so annoying it's so
annoying and every time they break up
with you it's because you were a
narcissist no it's like you cheated with
me I'm an 80 turns out I love autistic
girls they are no they're the best we've
been watching autistic dating love on
the Spectrum highly on that autistic
people trying to find love and it's like
I've come to find that you're like yeah
if you can find like an attractive
autistic woman it's perfect for me
because that's right because I like to
just be kind of alone like I like to
stay to myself like I don't really like
to talk too much it would be perfect you
just Gander a Nintendo DS
is good to go we were a toy train and
she ordered they organize all your stuff
for you too like like a lot like a lot
yeah I mean they get really anxious if
you miss the reservation though you
better be there on time they will
[__] lose their minds like if I [__]
them and then I want to go play video
games I just he'll go by the way I
bought you a new anime and then we'll
leave you alone I'm all happy they go in
a different room yeah I throw autistic
girls it's a win-win for everybody uh
OCD is a little bit different I have
dated an OCD girl as well like
legitimately OCD
um and that was that was actually kind
of annoying yeah because you had to like
turn the doorknob 50 times before you
left and stuff it's probably really it
was the light switches dude the light
switches it was like 50 times
no not at all it was really also it's
not even the good OCD it's not even the
good OCD no that's that's not even real
OCD like the people that are just super
organized that's autism right different
or they're different or I call them
Asians but I mean it's you know that's
that's the way I differentiate them like
yourself a tiger mom okay listen let me
tell you something
um Asian women either are really hot and
then they just turn into like Chinese
Chinese restaurant workers immediately
there's a little middle ground like they
just hit the wall and then they look
like they're training what's her face in
Kill Bill
wife has the opposite OCD where
everything's like too clean spotless
you'll be like where's my cell phone and
she'll be like oh you left it I threw it
on the table so I put it away in a
storage unit across town because you
keep leaving it laying all over the
house you're like it's decluttering I
was yeah it's not closer it's my phone
uh I sold it it's you you only use it 50
times last year it turns out that none
of your stuff Sparks Joy what
why is it my stuff where's my car I
parked it down the street it was
cluttering up the driveway it's a
driveway for the cars but look we had
you on last time this is the same
problem that happened last time you're
fun to hang out with we were talking
about bro you're where we left off
because we we went we went through the
for those that missed it the whole
interviews clipped on our on our YouTube
clip Channel you go watch it there and
it's on Rumble as well
um but for those that are know quick
catch up you were in the best way now
everyone knows it but the Shiny Happy
People cult the Duggar family called and
uh you basically got kicked out because
you were cocksmith if I remember
correctly uh you couldn't stop [__]
and um but you know honestly all that
[__] dude after the interview I even
went online there's so much [__] I'm
[__] YouTube about it like people
that's crazy and it's it's wild and it's
like you know people a lot of people
talk about like Colton a lot of people
think it's like it's like Heaven's Gate
I'm like yeah I mean that is a call that
wasn't called but at least but this is
like
this is happening now and and it's and
it's wild to me so last we left off was
you escaping it how did that happen
yeah so really my Escape From The Cult
was kind of anti-climactic I just told
my parents like hey I'm done with this
stuff I'm not doing it anymore I got
back from Indianapolis so that was the
compound that I was at for you know
basically Rehabilitation uh I got kicked
out of that by uh Bill Gothard so I had
like a sit-down meeting with Bill
Gothard and he said hey you got to go
basically um so what what happened there
was there was a a director uh one of the
leadership guys at the uh the compound
that I was at and he had two very
attractive daughters uh and I was I was
pretty upset uh about my my girlfriend I
thought my girlfriend had abandoned me
because they were intercepting all my
mail
um and this uh whoa whoa hold on sorry I
I just that's illegal yeah I don't think
so we didn't they were intercepting your
mail yeah so they were just yeah so they
were just grabbing it anything anything
that came through so I told I told the
the girl that I had been dating that I
got in trouble for where I was going uh
the address so she could you know send
me correspondence or whatever uh and uh
apparently she sent me a bunch of
letters and they intercepted all of them
and sent them to my parents instead so I
don't know if that's how they got around
the federal law that because you're
right I mean if you open someone else's
mail that's a federal crime right uh but
yeah I guess they sent them to my
parents or something I thought she'd
just abandoned me and so you know that
kind of added insult to injury for me so
I was already upset you know this uh
this uh leadership guy at the compound
had his two hot daughters and so I
decided to uh you know kind of take out
my anger on them and that's what I
ultimately got in trouble for
yeah I mean but they didn't know they
didn't have proof right no one could
prove anything they just had suspicions
because they'd caught us fraternizing
you know it's wild when you could even
see when you're saying it now like they
didn't have proof like like it does feel
like you were in a mini government like
a mini a mini tribunal a little trial
that you had to go through like it
didn't matter it's it's kind of like you
know how like reservations have their
own police like where they do their own
thing like Indian reservations have
their own police they handle all their
stuff internally it kind of feels like
that and also watching the documentary
you see they cover up a lot of [__] for
other people if you're high enough
though you get away with you know I'm
not literally murder but you know
yeah I mean close to it yeah I mean they
covered up all kinds of different sex
scandals
um you know the the Bill Gothard that's
why he was you know eventually taken out
was for for grooming uh and
inappropriate relationships with a lot
of young women and underage girls as
well
um but uh yeah it very much what there
was like a hierarchy there so originally
I got in trouble with the guy who led
the the rehabilitation program this was
a guy his name was Brandon McDonald and
here's a really super fun factoid that I
found out literally just last week so
this guy was an absolute Tyrant uh he
had a chip on his shoulder he had gone
through the paramilitary program I
believe uh and he was just the guy was
an absolute [__]
um he was the one that originally
interrogated me he was the one
intercepting the mail he's the one that
decided to send me to solitary
confinement uh I found out last week uh
that after many years in the program he
finally uh came out of the closet he was
he was a gay dude the whole time that's
why he was so angry he was living this
crazy lie I'd be so mad if I was gay I
said I'd be so mad if I was gay what are
you talking about dude I'd be so happy
I mean I was gay dude half my problem's
gone gone yeah but if you were gay you
probably you might still be in there
because you wouldn't be such a [__]
cocksmith
besides I would have gone to a different
kind of Camp yeah besides the Mike Pence
one but somebody shock you listen my
dick got me into nothing but trouble in
my younger years right but I got it like
how old are you
uh 39. oh you're all right so yeah so
yeah don't worry don't worry give it a
couple years it'll start calming down so
so how long have you been out like total
like since what you left how long have
you been out so I I got out when I was
18. and that's kind of when I gave my
parents the ultimate I'm like hey I'm
done with this cold stuff I'm not doing
it anymore I'm done with this whole this
whole thing I'm gonna go ahead and do
you know my own thing now and they were
actually like pretty cool with it and
they left the cult as well about a year
afterwards
they'd already kind of started seeing
like hey this is there's some weird
stuff going on here
so
um when how was it transitioning a
normal life dude dude that was so it was
it was like a out of The Frying Pan into
the fire thing for me
um not not everyone takes the path that
I did but I mean I'd been through some
traumatic stuff
um but I quickly discovered uh drugs
after I I got out of the cold I was
already like into alcohol and kind of
experimenting uh with drugs at that
point but after I was fully out and
started going to college I mean I went
into it like balls deep uh into uh into
substance abuse so
I would say for like the first three
years or so after I got out of the cold
it was still very recreational uh but
around the time I hit like 21 22 uh I
was like I was into like full-blown
addiction at that point
um and it got I mean it was it was dark
and and the first that this always like
shocks people because everyone says that
you know uh plant-based drugs uh
psychedelics those are like your your
gateways right not for me my first drug
the first drug I ever did was blow the
very first drug uh yeah and so popping
in a deep end yeah you went right in huh
I got the floaties bro just throw me in
uh
you want a joint no thanks only cocaine
for me no I'm an adult thank you I've
been through some things how about you
bust out that white powdery substance
let's get real again also I love how
nowadays don't touch weed kids it's a
gateway drug and they'll be like but
you're all on pharmaceutical
amphetamines yeah they're all snorting
Adderall but weed's the Gateway and it's
like they're six you're giving them myth
I'm pretty sure they're going to put
Jason some dopamine rushes when they're
older great dude when I finally got
sober I wasn't even doing street drugs
anymore which is really bad I did
everything so backwards I started with
street drugs and then ended up on
Pharmaceuticals Jesus and Adderall dude
I was doing like that's at one point I
was doing like 250 milligrams of
Adderall a day like I was out of control
what were you a hummingbird
I was living in a fever dream my reality
was a fever dream it was crazy I do have
to agree though that uh you know and
I've observed it just like when I went
to private school for a couple years
right and I just went to a Christian
private school but it was and it was an
occult but it was a very tight-knit
community and everybody kind of hung
around each other and it's not like you
know you had neighbor friends but for
the most part a lot of get-togethers
were in the church and uh when you break
away from that I went to public school
and I got kind of gradually kind of you
know aged into like Words travel with
smoke cigarette behind the school and
then it was like yeah you know drink
like two beers whoa and then it's like
we'll smoke a little weed and I got
eased into it so I didn't have as crazy
of a [__] early life man the ones
that stayed in that private school all
the way to 12th grade and I went to
college I heard [__] horror stories
oh like the chicks becoming just the
biggest [__] [__] on the planet
drugs and this and that I'm flunking out
I'm like yeah you can't just throw them
into the game like that it's a little
rough oh dude those uh those private
school Rich Kids man like so I lived up
in the Northeast for a little while uh
up near uh Massachusetts in New York and
and there was a little private school
um and this is when I was still being uh
homeschooled at the time uh and my mom
decided to uh enroll Us in the choir
program there and that was like one of
my early exposures to normal people uh
dude those kids were insane it was a
private boarding school basically a you
know like uh uh what do they call it
like a funnel schooled into the Ivy
Leagues right all those kids came from
old money and all this and they were
nuts I mean the amount of drugs those
kids did was insane now now oh yeah I
remember that school right now Matt
Damon was mean to the Jewish kid oh yeah
yeah yeah
that one Brendan Frazier was there I
believe so he played a Jewish guy look
it's been a long time since I went to
that school I don't know yeah I don't
know a lot of times I was a kid so so
you got so so you went from like cult
then plunged into drugs so that's
obviously an adjustment and then you
come out of that [__] side of things
how did you adjust to becoming boring
yeah it that that's been the hardest
part honestly like becoming a total
[__] has really been the most
traumatizing
I'm in bed by 11 and I drink I drink tea
now what's that about I just no I
shotgun Red Bulls and chain smoke
cigarettes that's kind of my thing now
oh I'm not gonna lie I was so proud of
how I had everybody just leaning and
going why he's about that he's about
this a deep question I had everybody
what do you mean boring I had everyone
on that one so wait so so you so you so
you got clean you went to rehab I'm
assuming uh no no dude raw dog actually
I sent my ex-fiance to rehab got her
into a rehabilitation program because
clearly you know towards the end of my
addiction I found this girl she was
going to be my my Saving Grace right
right
um but she was also when I met her she
was on methadone I didn't know it but I
was still you know running a gun and and
she finally admitted to me like oh by
the way I'm on method and I was like
great that means we can really party
together and so we just went down the
rabbit hole uh she she went to she went
to rehab I actually took her to rehab
completely loaded which is insane but uh
yeah so
sorry he said based
honestly bro is pretty good it's pretty
cool
so she ended up getting kicked out of
rehab though because she had uh she had
brought some some pills in with her yeah
not only do you smuggle drugs in for
your own use rehab soap proceed and hand
them out to everybody else get everybody
else and you're like look I was
homeschooled they told me to bring some
for everybody okay what do you want from
me I'm just trying to share I'm trying
yeah I like how this person is I like
how she's well-meaning but doing the
worst possible thing you could possibly
do in a rehab no she literally took out
the entire detox that she was into it
was insane movie
yeah
[__] stabbed getting their hours cut
it's hilarious now no doubt now of
course back then of course it wasn't but
looking back yeah it's all man crazy and
I mean you know how she smuggled him in
of course I mean yes of course yeah
let me guess she paid off a guard no I
don't think so I don't think I like to
tuck it in through a window uh well I'm
gonna go film canister with a little
foil over it and pop that up in your
prison pocket and you're good to go
so he's like yes I was in this cult
right this weird cult and then I get
into drugs then I found this thing
called narcanon I don't know if you've
ever heard of it these wonderful people
the scientologists run it and that's how
you you're like no no no no no stay on
drugs to another
uh so I I do I do like that you that you
you shut up their Hammer like look you
have a problem we need you need I
believe that's called the entertain
closet the lover boy method the lover
boy I've been there I've been there like
I've I've had women that were so out of
control in my life that I've been like
coked out of my face and drunk and
giving them a speech about how they need
to get it together so okay clean this up
this is ridiculous yeah you're making us
look really bad I'm a functioning addict
and you're [__] spinning out
gaslighting isn't real you're just crazy
we're not working at a strip club down
there you're gonna get us both fired so
so you said it wasn't rehab for you how
did you how did you uh clean up no so so
I actually when she got kicked out of
rehab I went to go find her uh so I
drove like an hour and a half to go find
her and when I decided that I was gonna
go look for her I knew I've got to have
all my faculties about me right so I
decided not to take any pills drink it
all I was just gonna go over there and
and really focus on finding her which
was a huge well I mean it really was a
huge mistake I don't recommend anyone do
this
um so I I actually did end up finding
her but then she she basically turned me
down said I don't want to go with you
you need to forget about me just leave
me alone go home so I did but by the
time I got back to my place uh it had
been 24 hours since I'd had anything in
my system which my body was not used to
not ready for so I ended up I pulled
into my driveway at my house and had a
seizure in the car whoa like that was
yeah that was that was my detox uh and
um you know after I had that seizure
you know I kind of had to make some hard
decisions at that point but I ended up
you know deciding I gotta I gotta do
something different this is crazy I
can't keep going like this and so I I
detoxed on my sofa like a couple friends
came over you know helped me out through
that process because I mean dude I was
on okay so when I got sober I was
drinking at least a bottle of whiskey
pretty much every night I was doing a
ton of Adderall a ton of Oxycontin and a
ton of Xanax I mean unsafe amounts right
so the detox itself the first week was
the worst
um and then after that it kind of like
honestly the alcohol part of the detox
was the worst I would say the the opiate
the opioid detox that sucked a lot but
from a physical perspective it just felt
like I had a really really severe case
of the flu like that's what I would I
went through the same detox was did you
do did you and you was it was like pills
you said right you weren't like on fence
or like dope or anything right no I
gotten off all that like I I used to do
you know black tar Brown clown I used to
used to eat fentanyl lollipops Dilaudid
like all that fun stuff yeah yeah that
is pretty awesome
favorite of mine our producer Virgie
also used to Traverse the the heroin
Highway if you will I I got into him
during the [__] the tail end of the
pill Mills being open here and we had
like I because I used to sell Coke and
then my body started working at this
better strip club and he's like look I
can get you in there as the main DJ
you're gonna make [__] good money
again but you can't sell Coke anymore
like it's because they already have
people selling Coke you know what I mean
like you're gonna get in trouble like
fine deal made better money anyway but
then I wasn't selling Coke anymore and
I'm like [__] I was really fiending for
Coke so that was when people were just
selling like they literally had sandwich
bags full of Percocets I mean everyone
they weren't pressed they weren't fake
everyone just had bags of [__] real
Percocets all over the place and I ended
up it was so easy to start eating like
four five six seven eight eventually a
day of those things and then all of a
sudden they shut down the pill Mills and
everybody's like I could get you dope
and I was like no I'll just go be sick
for two months
I started on dope and then moved the
pills Jesus uh which is so bad you you
did everything like the opposite way
like yeah the first thing I did was coke
that's what every that like when I tell
my story to people they're always just
like wait you you did heroin and then
you switched to pills because usually
it's the opposite way because pills are
so expensive but shout out Dr Arthur
Hernandez here in San Antonio and yes I
will say his full name because that guy
is a bastard uh I mean he'll give you as
any pills as you want I was actually I
thought you were gonna say like he's a
good doctor but in the back of my mind
I'm thinking that sounds like a shady I
don't know if you saw Melanie's new
special but it was [__] hilarious
mullaney was talking about him going
through rehab and going through all that
and he goes you know people everyone's
like yeah you know trust doctors he goes
um not every doctor and he was like you
know how I got my drugs he was hilarious
he goes I would go to you know those
doctor rating places and I'd go by sort
by lowest and whoever's at the bottom
they'll give you anything you want
because yeah he was like my doctor was a
was a kitchenette like in the Bronx that
he was you know going to someone's house
so it it really is easy you find the
right doctor they'll give you whatever
you want so I guess that's a good point
and it's also a lot less dangerous than
going to certain neighborhoods to buy
[__] too you know depending very much
and the insurance companies are you know
they're making thousands millions of
dollars a year off the insurance
companies and meanwhile you're a
full-blown junkie without even realizing
I mean they've cracked down on that kind
of stuff a lot lately uh but still man
it was this was you know this was like
10 15 years ago hopefully you got some
free Pfizer Pence out of it like [__]
farmer reps get at least that would have
been nice right at least I had some swag
I would have I would have sold all that
stuff so to get more drugs so when so
when you so okay so so that that detox
sounds horrible
especially you and that's what I got raw
dog in it that's like I'm [__] just
doing it you know you're legitimately
lucky to be alive yeah yeah because
that's that's right yeah
that's why I say that's that's wild bro
it's it's insane and anyone who who asks
me about this kind of stuff go go to a
doctor do a medical detox that is the
only way that you should be detoxing
even if you don't think you're like a
bad addict like you don't have a severe
problem like like potentially I had uh
still go to a doctor medically detox
because you never know how your body's
gonna react uh I mean it can kill you
real quickly so okay so you so you
cleaned up and then at that point where
you already
did you go immediately into comedy
no dude no so I was uh when I got sober
I was actually playing in uh in a couple
different bands
um well I was trying to play in a couple
different bands but I kept getting
kicked out of my own bands uh because I
was just such a mess and a nightmare
um you know so I I at that point once I
got sober I decided you know what trying
to play music right now is probably not
the best thing for me I don't want to
put myself back in that environment
necessarily so I just decided to focus
on my career at that point uh and I was
actually like pretty successful in in my
corporate life uh but about actually
like right right before the pandemic so
about four years ago I decided that uh
Corporate America was not for me anymore
I just wasn't enjoying myself I I didn't
care about you know making the money and
climbing the ladder anymore so that's
that's actually when I started doing
comedy was about four years ago yeah
Amen brother [__] corporate life
[__] sucks dude I'm awful this this
is I mean like man we're lucky we just
tell stupid dick jokes for money it's
great right like I mean honestly it's
great but so when so did did you find
yourself because you know you said
detoxing out of out of the drugs but did
you did you have to mentally detox from
being in a call I mean you had to have
right you have to be like learning
Behavior what was that lying
that I I think the the easiest way to to
explain it is how it affected my
relationships right uh because all of my
relationships you know dating trying to
get married you know being engaged to
this this this other girl that was also
a junkie uh the the cult mentality had
had permeated everything and I'd never
really processed out of it I just kind
of buried it with the drugs and alcohol
so once I got sober that's when I really
had to confront all that stuff and
figure out who the hell I really was
um and that was the toughest part that
was really the the getting sober part
like yeah it was it was it was painful
it was rough especially the first like
30 60 90 days uh but but realistically
after that for me it was really
unlearning all this old behavior and and
trying to figure out who I really was
and finding my own voice
um you know every single relationship
with with women and it's not as bad
anymore uh I would say like the past
five years I've really improved on that
but prior to that you dude every single
relationship I would get into would just
end up falling apart because you know I
was either over correcting on behavior
that I'd learned in the cult right like
it was very patriarchal
um which you know some people have
different thoughts about you know
Patriots or patriarchal versus
matriarchal societies but ours was like
women must submit at all times your man
is your ultimate Authority and that just
that that never worked for me that kind
of mentality um and so I would try to
over correct and end up you know with
this real [__] feminine energy all the
time and and women you know couldn't
really tell if I if I liked them at all
if I even cared about them and so it was
this constant back and forth uh with me
and women uh and finally I started
correcting that about five years ago but
that's that's part of that mentality
that I brought with me from the cult
that and just this insane guilt complex
over really anything that still
contradicted the way that I grew up so
you know going to church religious
affiliations a lot of social issues that
you know I would probably tend to fall
more on the liberal side as opposed to
the conservative side I mean I over
corrected so hard after I got sober I
will never forget dude my mom was in
town we uh we went out to dinner and
we're sitting there talking about a lot
of different like social things that
were going like hot button issues in
society especially like the lgbtq uh
stuff and um she she got really serious
and leaned across the table and just in
this Applebee's in the middle of
boneless buffalo wings goes are you gay
you can tell me it's okay I'll still
love you and I was like no Mom can I can
I be honest mom can I be honest she
probably asked you because you ordered
the boneless wings oh that's what it was
yeah that's a good point are you sure
did the regular Wings is way gayer than
boneless what are you talking about
boneless wings are just chicken nuggets
yeah that's like biting into a tender
breast
you're just sucking on a penis you know
I don't know man I don't know if I don't
know if I don't really think of sucking
dicks when I'm eating a wing but yeah
again I wasn't an occult so I don't know
when you're eating boneless wings Davey
it's like eating a bunch of tiny men's
testicles so you're [__] either way
you're literally ripping flesh from the
bone I doubt it would be you know what I
mean tiny testicles first of all if I
was gonna eat testicle they'd be huge
okay that's number one hey David he
would get he would eat the kind of
testicles you need a knife and a fork
for
hey you could tell us if you're gay okay
it's okay we're gonna love you either
way will you still love me
so there you go that's there you go did
you find yours because I I'll like them
even more because I don't have to
compete with him for [__] are you
kidding me I'll be like yeah Davey come
out let's hang this guy is [__] 39
years old [__] full head of hair was
through a cult he looks way better than
our stupid asses that weren't in a
[__] cult yeah I hate it was the
heroine that preserved my skin that's
what I tell everyone
aldehyde gets in your system and then
you're just young forever oh so okay so
that that that's something that I that I
watching a bunch of videos and stuff
like that it's that that guilt it
probably the guilt is probably the
hardest to get over right like like the
the the the you know what you're doing
logically is not wrong but you have that
trained Behavior like oh this is wrong
this is bad this is wrong that that had
to be like probably one of them I mean
outside of the drugs one of the hardest
things to get over
well here's the thing because the drugs
help cover up a lot of that guilt
complex right like I've been told my
whole life pre-marital sex is wrong
it'll send you to hell you're supposed
to you know preserve your virginity for
marriage right and so when I was on
drugs I didn't have to think about that
right while I'm slamming some some girl
uh well now I'm sober and I'm having to
think these These Old dots right that
were drilled into me no pun intended
during my childhood uh and and I don't
have a way to to deal with it other than
trying to disentangle myself from from
those old ideologies and I think going
back to what you said about the
patriarchal thing a lot of people think
that like this is like a patriarchal
thing like the way women go like oh my
God a man has a job that's not the
patriarchal this is what actually what
it was it's and I know they they bring
it up in the documentary but they bring
up like you know basically you could be
you're certain the way I describe is a
certain cast right yeah and that women
were always the mercy cast which is like
you do whatever the [__] you told you
all you do is you bear everybody else's
burdens and stuff like that and and you
know you have to wear these pantaloons I
don't know what those [__] Dr what
those weird pantaloon dresses were or
whatever that was culottes culottes yeah
yeah that's what you're looking for yeah
it was it was it was it was weird so I
could see that absolutely affecting your
relate your your relationships too
because you know you you want to be like
kids always Rebel right like that's why
there's like there's a lot of Zoomers
now that are more like conservative
because you know the their dads their
parents were like yeah man you know
climate change or whatever so you Rebel
and I guess that happens too right when
you leave there you want to be like no
no no no no no I'm not I'm not like them
I'm completely different and over
correcting is something that I guess a
lot of people do oh yeah dude and and
just to your point about that patriarchy
stuff it's so poisonous it's so
incredibly poisonous and I love how you
you identified this this uh this Mercy
character quality right yeah every woman
seemed to be a sign like they were a
mercy servant character quality that's
their personality right and then every
man was a prophet teacher uh and so it
it just fit perfectly into into this
mold right where well men are going to
tell you what to do but that's just
their personality and you should be
listening and obeying anyway
um and so it just it has these uh
I I don't know it I just talked to this
guy who grew up in the fundamental
Latter-Day Saints where they still
practice polygamy and all this this
crazy [__] right and the stuff that he
was saying about how each family had a
profit and and all this different stuff
that he grew up with it was just like yo
that's that's exactly the same mentality
and ideology that the shiny people the
Shiny Happy People cult had minus the
polygamy which is really the only cool
part so there's no fun that sucks
exactly holy [__] all the downsides to a
cult at least sit next to him you were
banging people yeah what the [__] that's
at least if you follow the rules you get
like 15 wives you know what I mean yeah
in in flds but in iblp you follow all
the rules you still get you still only
get one wife yeah like he said the
Nexium thing it's like I'm giving you
all my property all my Earthly
possessions and I'm coming to join this
cult but the upside was at least they go
hey remember that show Smallville right
so hear me out you want to [__] some of
the checks from that show and you're
like I mean I'd like to know which ones
first yeah can I know which ones first
please and it turns out it's two of the
good ones turns out still the better
ones you're going in pretty sweet yeah
pretty good deal it it really you're
right it's like I really do want to [__]
Allison Mack I don't know it's just
something about you know the fact that
she was a crazy sex cult woman well I
heard she puts out that's what I mean
she's gotta be nuts weren't they using
her as bait for the cult right yeah yeah
it was into it man yeah and she liked it
it was weird like she she would he would
tell her that she was second in command
bro she's into some sick [__] as long as
it's not like illegal gross stuff yeah
but she's probably into some real
[__] wild [__] well yeah I mean she's
probably on the Spectrum dude she's
probably exactly my type
100 Amen brother and you could [__] and
you could bond over both being an occult
which is actually really really great uh
the trauma Bond there is there is no
stronger Bond than a trauma Bond you
guys just you could go through crying to
[__] to smoking cigarettes to crying
again and you can apply that to a lot of
different things like for instance let's
say you think your chick's leaving you
right maybe one night you purposely
crash your car right she doesn't know
you did that right but then you Bond
again this uh this sounds very specific
no I would never do actually do that no
he would never respect a woman are you
insane honestly and I crashed my car
enough I would never purposely have to
do it no no it always happens by mistake
long enough yeah try driving sober um so
again boring again Mercy doesn't want to
be bored do are you still in contact
with people that are still in in the
cult currently no dude I so I don't have
contact with hardly any of the people
that I I grew up in the cult with either
um aside from my family
um everyone else I I know there were
there were a couple families that I
stayed in contact with for a little
while
um but that you know those relationships
kind of fell apart especially as I got
like deeper into my drug addiction
um I do know there was one family that
um my parents started a home church with
and they had a bunch of smoking hot
daughters so I did keep track of them
for a little while uh but then they they
all they all married off uh to a bunch
of nerds of course a bunch of nerd dudes
that they got married to to be fair you
didn't you didn't miss much because you
got out of the cult you said when you
were like 18 right 19. so I mean it's
the same way what I mean I don't talk to
a lot of [__] I went to high school
with either yeah
your timing the cult doesn't prevent you
from that it's just 20 years goes by and
you're like I have nothing I have no
common interest with this guy anymore
maybe I could talk about the Jets for
five minutes yeah most of the chicks I
went to high school with are selling
multi-level marketing schemes and like
seaweed wraps now oh yeah the seaweed
wraps and the what are the other ones
the leggings the leggings yeah they're a
huge one yeah one of the ones that used
to be hot that wouldn't give you the
time of day and now they're divorced and
fat they're coming back around and
you're like get the [__] out of my face
yeah oh they always come back get the
[__] up beat it but yeah I I would I
would love to you know get in contact
with with a couple of I I've tried to
find so the the the two girls that I got
in trouble with when I was at uh the
compound in Indianapolis I've tried to
find them they are absolute ghosts
online I can't find any information
about them it also might be because I
have the wrong last name that could that
could also be part of it uh but yeah I
mean I've had people reach out that also
were at that compound uh since I did you
know the surviving the shiny half of
people uh cult podcast I've had folks
reach out and and they don't even know
how to get in touch with those people
which is great by the way I watched some
of them but I highly recommend a watch
if you're if there's look we're just
scratching the surface here like I I
know you go through you went through a
lot of stuff in that and and it's great
and I actually would it would actually I
do that's there you go you said you're
gonna find them do do they make you kind
of be off of social media like other
places because I know other like you
know tell you not to be on social media
not to be out there or how does that go
are you free to still like have a
Facebook and have an Instagram and that
a tick tock in that [__] I would imagine
the first 20 years A lot of them were on
social media right because Facebook had
just like kind of started back then
um and so some of them were on Facebook
but it was it was mostly like Bible
verses and pictures of them with their
family and that sort of thing so it was
more so like an Outreach to it like you
know you know how uh Mormons when they
go on their missions they use Facebook
to reach out to you know potential
proselytizing targets I think that's
primarily what they were using Facebook
and social media for as far Instagram
and Tick Tock I have no idea certainly
not Tick Tock I mean that's obviously a
spy app so we can't be using that uh but
uh yeah I mean I would love to get in
touch with some of them just to see how
they are uh because I I you know I I
remember one of uh one my buddies from
when uh my family still lived in Houston
and we were going to the church where I
met the girlfriend that I got in trouble
for and sent to rehab
um he reached out to me many many years
later uh because he'd found me on social
media and uh he reached out to me just
to just to tell me that he knew I was
going to turn into like this complete
derelict like you know as soon as as
soon as he met me he like the message
that he sent me was I knew that this was
going to be how you turned out because
at that point I was just an insane drug
addict playing in bands just being a you
know an absolute terrorist I would have
been like that yeah thanks dude thanks
bro yeah congratulations on on getting
fat and finding an ugly wife because
that's that's what happened to him uh
the drugs kept me thin jokes on you
but like that's that's usually how I
react to anyone like if anybody comes up
to you know like yeah congratulations on
being a [__] drunk failure piece of
[__] I'll be like thanks bro because
that's the only way to react because
then they always get really mad you're
like oh dude thank you thanks man I'm
glad you know this wow really appreciate
you reaching out like that was cool
thanks thanks do me a favor make my
chicken McNuggets
give me a number ten yeah shut up and
make my order yeah shut up
my boneless chicken wings are burning I
can smell it
but yeah so so what what made you what
made you get into comedy because now you
have your special coming out very soon
uh what what made you get into comedy
man I I had been a fan of stand up uh
for a lot the first the first album I
ever bought uh was Mitch hedberg's album
[__] love and it was uh I think it
was a double CD that I bought uh and the
reason I bought his album was because
I'd heard he was like this out of
control drug addict uh and I was doing a
lot of drugs at the time so I think this
was when I might have been like 19 or
20.
um maybe 21 at that point uh and so I
bought that album listen to it I was
just like this is amazing and I'd
watched other stand-up Clips before like
back then it was on uh stupid videos and
e-bombs world uh e-bombs world babe and
then break.com I remember all those
places oh break.com yeah that was
another good one yeah so I'd watch these
stand-up clips and I'd always been
fascinated by it but my passion was
always music and so once I decided that
you know I wasn't gonna play in bands
anymore
um you know I was kind of looking for
something else that I could do I started
making some like sketch videos but uh
like I said about four years ago I went
to my first stand-up comedy open mic got
on stage told some jokes it actually
went surprisingly well for someone who'd
never been on stage telling jokes before
um and I was I mean that honestly like
getting laughs from a crowd like that it
felt like a fat hit a crack and I was
like all right we're gonna we're gonna
do this this is this is what I'm doing
now I mean that's awesome and by the way
chat [__] love me Shepard
um one of the fun funny one of the
[__] funniest dudes uh in in so so
you so you got into that you got into
comedy how are you how are you well
you're a Comics you can't be all there
but how are you feeling now
comparatively to how you were uh you
know years ago you feeling like you know
you you're you're hitting your shride
now or oh dude yeah so as far as like
with comedy I'm only four years in uh
but I've had like so many like some of
the coolest opportunities dude like I've
I've gotten to perform with guys like
Tim Dylan uh Mark Norman Ed Bassmaster
was amazing love that dude I've done
I've done a lot of stuff with JP Sears
I'm sure you all know JP yeah
um you know I've just gotten uh some
really really cool opportunities uh and
so it's it's been like uh uh I have a
lot I've gotten a lot of momentum really
quick uh so I'm super grateful for that
and now getting to do this special uh
I'm actually recording the special this
weekend and then we're gonna edit it
super fast turn around and publish it in
like middle of August I think and
obviously you know dropping it on uh
just streaming platforms because who
goes to Netflix anymore to try to get a
deal you know but bro look at [__]
Ari shaffir drop this on YouTube his
juice special which [__] amazing by
the way killed it's so yeah yeah I mean
it's like you you do your [__] on your
own man I feel like Shane Gillis kind of
opened the flood guys that's another
buddy of mine yeah we love Shane gas
we've had him on the show before too as
a matter of fact when we had changilla
song this is one of my favorite stories
that I'll tell people we had them on and
it just been recently after uh SNL uh
fired him or didn't hire him basically
and he goes hey do you mind if I Skype
in on Doug Stanhope Skype I'm at his
house I'm like yeah I don't care and he
comes on and they were up all the night
before like doing drugs and they were
both hungover and so then I had like
Doug Stan up with him just remember
immersed completely hung over on the
show
it was one of my favorite interviews of
all time yeah yeah yeah he's dude that
guy is a com
you know which one was really slept on
though was the um their little like
militia video yeah the militia video
that they did and him like basically
coming to attention and saluting that
[__] cracked me up dude I thought that
was so [__] funny and so slept on
they they literally filmed the pilot
about a [__] tire shop and it's some
of the funniest [__] I've ever seen and
if you just told me like you I don't
know I was just gonna be you guys in a
tire shop I'd be like where it's what's
the yeah how is that supposed to be
funny but then if you told me who's in
it I'd be like all right that's when I
was like I gotta check this out it's
some of the funniest [__] oh yeah and
they're just two idiots so we're gonna
[__] tire shop it's great he's so
good man his Trump impression impression
or impersonation whatever you want to
call it uh I mean I I think unrivaled in
the industry best Trump impersonation by
far it's dude our audience is gonna get
mad at him now though oh because Marsh
is Trump Marsha is more the tired Trump
uh yeah well I used to do the tire Trump
but lately I've been doing the black
Candace Owens folks
she betrayed me I talked about the vex
broke my heart frankly yeah I got an
okay one the black Cannon someone's this
week he starts in I guess that would be
on trumpet well yeah because you had the
hands going at the same time oh I was
but it's cut off because of the way I
felt I was actually doing it but it was
off camera but uh yeah no that came from
a black-handed soda I said wow she's so
black well that bit came from when we
were making fun of the fact that Trump's
really like lost Steam from the old
Trump doesn't have the energy he has
anymore and he doesn't have like his
nicknames aren't as funny and he's not
as he's just not he's not hitting the
mark like he used to and he seems kind
of passionless and I'm like he's running
out of [__] to say and it's lazy and I'm
like when he came up with uh calling uh
Ron uh meatball Ron he's like Ron
DeSantis meatball Ron and I love that
one I don't like Rhonda sanctimonious I
thought that one was lazy but he's just
getting ball wrong was like hey he used
to be better and then and then like I
just feel like I was like when Candace
Owens question him about the facts and I
was like he's just getting lazy he's
gonna go out and country social and be
like black and the sounds folks because
he's like not even realizing that's not
necessarily an insult you're just
running out of bed nicknames dude
yeah man it's a good one [__] dude
it's it is I honestly think some of the
I think the two of the best people for
instance during sketches right now are
Shane Gillis and Tim Robinson those are
two of like oh dude I think you should
leave his ruin my life
because it's it's so stupid and so
[__] hilarious yeah love it all the
time that guy is not like well he's
another one that SNL got rid of he's not
mentally well he's another one SNL got
red every time I SNL get rid of somebody
they're [__] awesome that's what
always happens I very rarely watch Cops
and oh go ahead my problem with I think
you should leave is I find it so funny
and then I'll have like a female friend
over and I'll be like hey you gotta
watch it
so you kick them out and I can't respect
them yeah no that's true it honestly I
saw that article that says Tim Robinson
broke my boyfriend and I'm like that's
because all we do is if I know anybody
watches it all we do is just quote it
back and forth are you sure about that
are you sure that's not reason why all
the time this all ties into like the
feminism and the but not binary and the
[__] [__] everybody's trying to be
something they're not and it's like look
women aren't funny and if they're gonna
watch Tim Robinson and not most of them
aren't going to live because they're not
inherently funny and that's fine let's
quote Sarah Silverman I said I am not
saying there are not exceptions to the
rules there's Exceptions there are how
amazingly funny women I don't know a
single funny woman who's a functioning
woman
they're not functioning as a woman like
most of them are [__] insane right
like the women that make me laugh I'm
like holy [__] yeah but you're [__]
nuts and your life's a mess so yeah he
gave me Schumer is so funny dude you're
such a [__] [__] you know that one
of my favorite Norm Macdonald jokes is
like who's funnier than so Silverman you
know except a bunch of dudes dude she's
so unfunny that she married an autistic
guy so she has an excuse for why she
doesn't make her husband laugh no Amy
Schumer was great when [__] Justin
like was writing your jokes for her dude
jessalnet man oh man that guy yeah that
guy's a genius that guy's a flat out
genius [__] hilarious this was smug
it really is okay
there's that part yeah I mean most
Geniuses are though joke writing I I
write I write off Comics the minute they
start kind of like you know doing the
whole Like These people aren't what
they're doing there shouldn't be a lot
of platforms and stuff that I'm like oh
boy oh boy just be funny please I want
to like you pal the reason that got me
the the piss us off is when you wrote
that whole thing on like you know Big
Jay oakerson and like Legion of skanks
like Jackson wrote this whole like oh I
don't know these guys are all like white
supremacists he had to walk it back
later but they would pick Jay's like
[__] what yeah are you serious yeah
there's a whole article I didn't even
know yeah yeah there was this whole
article Canadians are awesome until like
you they start sharing their real
opinions and then you're like just shut
the [__] up dude just be funny dude I I
do a lot of like sketch videos uh and I
never share my opinion most people think
I'm like this this crazy maga maga
Republican uh and in fact I'm I'm not I
just love making fun of Joe Biden
because it's so easy to do it's kind of
hacky uh but it's so easy to do but I've
also made fun of trump
hates all of that [__] he doesn't even
pay attention to politics and he writes
some of the best political sketches yeah
and people are like wow he's right-wing
or wow he's left-wing he's like no I'm
an idiot I don't care about you don't
like Andrew take that he drives a
Bugatti a Bugatti and bottled water
bottle okay so a lot of these cars are
rented or leased so what so what
immediate immediately with the you gotta
do
you're stuck in The Matrix
all right did you see did you see that
uh that clip from uh uh Adam 22 and Lena
the plug uh on no jumper no but I I saw
the other table made
oh how was it
about this big if I if I may if I made
Davey that's the first time she actually
looked like she was enjoying the dick
that was going on it was dude I'll tell
you what I saw a cliff of it it looked
like an old Samsonite commercial oh my
God like Patrice like Patrice said his
dick was so big it had an elbow
why does it look like a little person's
leg that's crazy I uh I I saw a uh uh so
adam22 filmed the video after Lena did
her uh her BBC scene right and he bought
her a a green lime green Lamborghini SUV
right and it was it was poorly acted
just just like all her other videos but
uh she's like saying how much she
appreciates it oh my God thank you babe
he goes in to kiss her she kisses him
but you can tell he's still going in for
the deeper kiss and she she pulls back
and turns away dude that guy that video
that oh that oh yeah broker oh yeah no
absolutely maybe he just didn't want to
snowball him but like it's no it's more
like an avalanche at that point oh I
know what those lips have been that's an
avalanche that's a
snow bank he pulled back from the kiss
she did yeah Adam wanted to go in deeper
she pulled back yeah I mean it's it look
I I think with a lot with her look we
know he's know her she's she's trying to
get as much out of this as she can in
terms of publicity and this and that and
then you know she's gonna move on like
you know and to be fair I'll give Adam
22 credit on on this one point which I
don't think he gets a lot of in terms of
Leaning into it like the other day he
was I guess I gotta he did tweet
something to make me laugh because I
guess I gotta find a black guy to [__]
me so it's fair which is funny which
that's a funny joke does it matter you
like him or not that was a very funny
joke and he's made a lot of money off of
it and all that stuff too but like tons
of money what costs though you know what
I mean but then again he already has
face tattoos like I mean come on what's
he gonna do you know be a shorter to
cook at Waffle House if he's not this
hey well let's not disrespect The Waffle
House first of all that's like one of my
favorite places they don't have a lot of
them in Texas well I know you I know you
know you love it
I know you love it you you're a drug
addict every drug addict
ing I'm naturally drawn to it yeah
but no I actually I I like adam22 stuff
uh he he kind of I mean soft white
underbelly originally exposed Sharpie to
the world you guys know who Sharpie is
yeah yeah and now he's on no jumper and
I love that guy I love watching that
guy's stuff he is unhinged yeah dude
everything is unhinged now though I mean
is there some of the best stuff now I
think I think we got an over we've got
to kind of past that I we're getting
past that over censorship stuff where
people are actually being funny again
and that's partly to do with Twitter
opening up a bit and being able to be on
Rumble and stuff like that and kind of
say you know except for like calls the
fight calls to violence Nick Fuentes uh
besides that Nick Fuentes was uh he did
like an entire speech about click we're
gonna have to kill the Jews I'm like
come on man we're telling jokes over
here relax you know to say that same
thing happened to Theo Vaughn and
Roseanne Barr oh God I saw that she was
clearly joking it was so dripping yeah
with sarcasm and they removed it yeah
that's how they updude we I've said this
before we're not we we just recently got
we had we had like 44k on YouTube and
we'd have had more but we got to
monetize really early on in Shadow band
but we just got kicked off recently at
our channel was like five six years old
merch about five six years they kicked
us off and the last nail in the coffin
was for cyber bullying Jeffrey Epstein
I might I'm not even kidding Marshall
I'm not even kidding you I have the
email I saved and I'm gonna put it on
the wall it was for cyber bullying do
not get a plaque so we're not getting a
plaque with cyber bullying a dead
Jeffrey Epstein yeah that and it was a
video that was like four years old
how are you cyber bullying I don't
remember I actually found the video
because it was up on Rumble we back
everything up there and I watched and I
was like literally the whole video was
just going like this guy's a [__]
pedophile and he is oh yeah he already
killed himself yeah or no yeah I mean he
didn't Hillary because they blame us it
was an old video so my theory is that
they they blame us because it was an old
video and I'm they're thinking maybe he
watched it in jail and we bullied him
into killing himself yeah yeah well
that's not true there's no power
camera's in that jail so remember they
told us everything's fine don't ask
questions honestly what a flex if that I
mean you guys should lean into that we
killed Jeffrey Epstein YouTube said it
we bullied him into taking his own life
no let's not do that because then these
[__] corrupt [__] will find a way
that to take our statement Lee is
legally binding and then like JP Morgan
Chase will sue us for a billion dollars
yeah and they'll take her back and
they'll take our bank away like they did
beforeage took his bank away we make up
a funny story and we get Alex jonesed no
thanks yeah no [__] I've already got
enough overhead that's one of my
favorite guests Alex Jones to tell you
how our YouTube channel should have not
been around the first time we had Alex
Jones on he's like thank you boys thanks
for having me on really appreciate it I
know why I'm YouTube I'm gonna be good
merch will tell you 15 minutes in he was
like so we have to start killing
government officials I'm like God damn
hell Matthew McConaughey he's a
pedophile cocaine Adam yeah he come back
here pedophile cocaine doing this though
like all right well I ain't all right
let's [__] go you know let's [__]
go let's do it might as well yeah sure
who else oh [__] we're over time Jesus
Christ dude I just realized amen thank
you so much for coming on again get the
plugs out not the lean of the plugs no
not the Lena yeah well I mean that too
though honestly hit me up girl if you're
available I don't care either uh but I
uh the whole thing's on xhamster if
you're looking for it yeah right and
pretty much all the social media
platforms yeah that Davey Jacks
d-a-v-e-y-j-a-x and then I'm recording
uh my special this weekend Friday and
Saturday if you want to come just hit me
up dude we uh let us know when you're
down here man we're gonna [__] hang
I'll be down there next week hell yeah
we're gonna get into it in real life
bro IRL streaming we're gonna go yeah
we're gonna we're gonna do ip2 okay it's
a Bluetooth speaker
a bunch of n words playing on this no no
we're not those streamers we're not
those streamers but uh we're just now
what he meant was we're just gonna play
Eddie Murphy's first uh album yeah we
should play raw I'm Jewish so I'll be
your Baked Alaska yeah
thank you so much man dude of course you
come on whenever you want dude everybody
everybody loves you and you [__] you
you're killing it man I'm sure your
special's gonna rock the four years dude
you're [__] awesome I mean you're
very very funny you're a funny dude man
this is an easy hang sometimes I'll be
honest with you I won't name any names
but we have some guests and it's just
like
but y'all are so much fun to hang out
with thank you all so much you guys are
you you're welcome on whenever whenever
you want man when you come down here
we'll see you for sure thanks for coming
on dude hey thank y'all we really
appreciate it brother take it easy see
you later
uh we we gotta don't have them on
anymore because he's too handsome you
know he's he's way too handsome and it's
making us look like [__] [__]
he's awesome man thank he's he's great
go check him out